[Music]
one of the best known and most
successful video games of all time is
being made into a movie Minecraft has
sold over 300 million copies and
continues to excite countless Gamers so
we are all the more excited about the
movie adaptation in our new Original
Episode we provide you with all the
latest information on the plot cast and
production of the liveaction adaptation
Warner Brothers announced a Minecraft
movie back in 2014 and got millions of
players excited this anticipation was
soon dampened however the project
experienced several delays and cast
changes behind the scenes causing the
project to lose momentum meanwhile the
movie is getting back on track a release
date has been set and more and more
details are coming to
light the story of Minecraft originally
there were several ideas for the plot of
the Minecraft movie One for example
focus on the concept of a number of
people working creatively in a digital
landscape just like in the original game
another story option is more more likely
though the plot revolves around a young
girl and a group of special adventurers
they have to protect their beautiful and
blocky Overworld from the evil Ender
Dragon who leaves behind a path of
Destruction on his way similar to the
Super Mario Brothers movie we can expect
to see many locations from the game
featured in the movie including
different biomes and the hell-like
nether Dimension the Ender Dragon itself
usually awaits the player in a surreal
place called the end we are excited to
find out what the world of Minecraft
will be like in the movie after all the
look of the game is very unique further
details about the plot are not known at
present but we can assume that fun and
creativity will be the main focus of the
movie after all the world of Minecraft
offers countless opportunities to tell a
captivating story as numerous spinoffs
of the game have already proven we are
particularly looking forward to the
implementation of the strange creatures
above all of course the iconic creeper
and the
Enderman the Minecraft movie has been
able to secure some celebrity the actors
in April 2022 for example it was
announced that Jason Mamoa is to take on
a starring role in The Adventure film
Mamoa is considered one of the most
sought-after Blockbuster actors in
Hollywood he was already featured in
fast X in 2023 and made his return as
the main hero of Aquaman in the Lost
Kingdom at the end of the year according
to deadline magazine Wednesday star Emma
Myers will also be involved in keeping
with the story we are actually expecting
the femo protagonist here also in the
cast are what we do in the Shadow star
Matt Barry Orange is the New Black
actress Danielle Brooks as Dawn and
Sebastian Eugene Hansen as
Henry the Minecraft production has
already gone through a turbulent time in
2014 it was announced that free guy
director sha Levy would be adapting a
script by Kieran and Michelle morrone
who were already behind Sherlock Holmes
a game of shadows however due to
creative differences with Mojang the
game's creators the project was put on
hold temporarily almost 2 years later
it's always Sunny in Philadelphia Star
Rob meleny was to take over the movie
and write a screenplay together with
Jason fuches according to Insider
information the story of the movie at
the time focused heavily on the open
world aspects of the game but this also
came to nothing shortly before the
project was ready to be made the studio
management changed moh heny who left the
production in 2018 was succeeded by
director Peter solot but he too was
unable to stay with the project for long
in the end the choice fell on Jared Hass
who had already over audiences with the
comedy Napoleon Dynamite and is
considered a promising Talent the final
script was written by Chris Bowman and
Hubble Palmer who had previously worked
with Hess on the comedy
masterminds filming for Minecraft was
originally scheduled to begin in August
2023 due to the actors and writer strike
however there were a number of setbacks
now filming is scheduled to begin in New
Zealand in early
2024 distributor Warner Brothers intends
to release Minecraft in movie theaters
on April 4th
2025 let's hope everything runs smoothly
from now on we are particularly excited
about the look of the movie how do you
imagine the perfect adaptation of the
original game share your preferences in
the comments and like this video If you
enjoyed our little preview see you next
[Music]
time
oh